(Singing)
(Singing ends)
(Applause)
Pep Rosenfeld: Folks,
you've just met Claron McFadden.
She is a world-class soprano singer
who studied in Rochester, New York.
Her celebrated operatic roles
are numerous and varied.
In August 2007, Claron was awarded
the Amsterdam Prize for the Arts,
winning praise for her brilliance,
her amazing and extensively
wide repertoire
and her vivid stage personality.
Please welcome Claron McFadden.
(Applause)
Claron McFadden: The human voice:
mysterious, spontaneous, primal.
For me, the human voice is the vessel
on which all emotions travel --
except, perhaps, jealousy.
And the breath,
the breath is the captain of that vessel.
A child is born,
takes its first breath --
(Inhales)
Whah!
And we behold the wondrous beauty
of vocal expression --
mysterious, spontaneous
and primal.
A few years ago, I did
a meditation retreat in Thailand.
I wanted a place
where I would have total silence
and total solitude.
I spent two weeks at this retreat
in my own little hut --
no music, no nothing -- sounds of nature,
trying to find the essence
of concentration,
being in the moment.
On my last day,
the woman who looked after the place,
she came and we spoke for a minute,
and then she said to me,
"Would you sing something for me?"
And I thought, but this is a place
of total quiet and silence.
I can't make noise.
She said, "Please, sing for me."
So I closed my eyes,
I took breath
and the first thing that came up and out
was "Summertime,"
Porgy and Bess.
(Singing) Summertime
and the livin' is easy.
Fish are jumpin' and the cotton is high.
Oh, your daddy's rich
and your ma is good-lookin'.
So hush little baby,
don't you cry.
And I opened my eyes,
and I saw that she had her eyes closed.
And after a moment, she opened her eyes
and she looked at me and she said,
"It's like meditation."
And in that moment I understood
that everything I had gone
to Thailand to look for,
to search for,
I had it already in my singing --
the calm, but alertness,
the focus, but awareness,
and being totally in the moment.
When you're totally in the moment --
when I'm totally in the moment,
the vessel of expression is open.
The emotions can flow from me
to you
and back.
It's an extremely profound experience.
There's a piece by a composer,
an American composer called John Cage.
It's called "Aria."
It was written for an amazing singer
called Cathy Berberian.
And the thing about this piece
that's so special --
if you see it behind me --
it's not notated in any way.
No notes, no flats, no sharps.
But it's a kind of structure.
And the singer, within this structure,
has total freedom
to be creative, spontaneous.
For example,
there are different colors
and each color gets
a different type of singing --
pop, country and western, opera, jazz --
and you just have
to be consistent with that color.
You see there are different lines.
You choose in your own tempo
in your own way
to follow the line,
but you must respect it,
more or less.
And these little dots,
these represent a sort of sound
that's not a vocal, not a lyrical way
of expressing the voice.
Using the body -- it could be sneezing,
it could be coughing, animals --
(Audience member coughs)
Exactly. (Laughter)
Clapping, whatever.
And there's different text.
There's Armenian, Russian,
French, English, Italian.
So within this structure, one is free.
To me, this piece is an ode to the voice,
because it's mysterious, as we can see.
It's quite spontaneous.
And it's primal.
So I would like to share
this piece with you,
It's "Aria," of John Cage.
(Singing in various languages)
Hampart-zoum
Dirouhi
Di questa Terra
Naprasno
Conscience et
(Barks)
(Singing) Arise
Tsk, tsk, tsk.
(Singing)
Vidiel’a
facilmente
E io sono per te
(Robotic voice) No other way
Dans l'espace, so help
(Singing)
Si juste
Dvidzénya bistri
(Claps)
(Singing)
On pekrásen
idyot a k u
O a k ho a
Sivayoot eternal loosin
(Sneezes)
(Laughs)
Shh!
(Singing)
Gloobinoí più chiara
Si ceci est cela cela est ceci
Totalmente soi whom they sought to slay
To have the fruits gloire
J’écoute ...
À la vie…
Leggermente snédznoi
Coo coo
P k t d
Banalité
K o e
(Makes the sound of a kiss)
(Singing)
In armonia
(Applause)